how's it going resume aren't you lucky
we're gonna create a Simpson a usually
for me at least the most fun part of
absense is to make your own character
and that oh shut up with oh god I did
not mean to do that I can just do that
what is what oh my god I haven't even
started I I have to explore I love big
boy too bad batches throw me a robot
well let's let's try and create the
ugliest girl in the world because ok
what's happening plastic surgery yep
FaceTime go okay she has all the details
how about that there we go that's cute
hair she looks like that actors from
vulner soros makeup maybe yeah that
looks pretty nice cute little nose you
got there very nice nose there's really
a lot of customization you can do here I
like it she look like she has an allergy
and bad things happen why does she look
so old I didn't mean threat to be old oh
god those ice so pretty fabulous oh god
that's a clothes please why does she
look so evil there's old ugly people
look evil is that exactly what this game
is trying to tell me there we go now
we're talking whoa what happened why is
it here so quick okay why not oh yeah
baby
this minute dared you to be I always
said subtlety is the key to beauty and I
think this really displays that oh god I
can make the pupil smaller oh my god
I've never been this scared in my life
oh god what is it wasn't me I swear to
god oh god what the [ __ ] what happened
why did he all right then we got them
sags or we got them the Pumped Up
silicones ones I guess we'll go with
that
oh god don't do that please for the love
of God so cute in a weird way like she
doesn't look bad should this looks
extremely ugly so pretty what should she
wear Musha Musha indeed that food was
just about to say that booty can't get
any bigger but I was wrong oh how wrong
I was
oh gosh that's not look that great oh my
god oh my god amazing this became a
Shrek I didn't mean for it to happen but
it happened
hello my name is Sally Mac psyched it's
wonderful let's click Save okay so none
of these are hardly ever as pretty as
mine yeah I think mine is the best
alright let's do this bold kind of look
like Heisenberg already I don't even
know how I did that did you see about my
glasses bro
what do you say about my earrings bruh
what do you say about my necklace rah ah
come on take off the hat man we know
you're bald underneath oh um getting
good oh god yes you are yes you are
Heisenberg so cute
it looks like y'all have some bug let's
get naked there you go nice going high
sandbag
yeah there's muscle whoa oh yeah that's
what I'm talking about Heisenberg get
some tattoos up there nice boots by the
way I don't know if I complimented you
ever on that slowly becoming more and
more fabulous slowly someone skipped leg
day there we go oh god what just
happened what did I do
it strickenberg that's what it is that's
my Shrek issue oh my god it's Bebe's
nothing screams manliness as a pink
goatee or a moustache he's like Oh
custom a custom a please I'm sorry can
someone just like us me so cute you suck
your it looks even better with the
clothes it's a pro I'm a scholar bro ya
walk like you mean it girl I mean boy oh
that is we got to do something about
that oh yes sorry mother Oh God in or
out
in this will be Steven max act it and
let's save him let's let's finish off by
trying to make me alright first off we
have to find my hairstyle
that's the closes I can think of so we
either have a redhead or way too blonde
yeah that's it that's it
finally it right now I look like a very
handsome Asian man this is not makeup I
come on ancient man don't get way to
makeup that's [ __ ]
I took how does it my eyes look like huh
how great they're just my eyebrows are
disproportionate now I didn't know I can
do that it's really hard gotta get that
Leno chin nice nice
goddammit this is too hard I can't even
[ __ ] do it doesn't even look anything
like me I had lunch nothing like me and
I'm supposed to be in this family
goddammit alright that's enough fun of
this damn obras I had a lot of fun
creating these sims for your breads I
hope you had fun watching if you did
thank you for leaving like I really
appreciate it and thank you for leaving
in comment I'll see you in the next
video or whatever we make stay awesome
Prez